All right, let's take a look at these--now, in order to figure out the percentage of improvement
for this first question, we need to figure out the actual cost for each of these tours.
So if we look at the improved shorter tour, the cost is 20 when we add all these up,
and similarly for the true path, the cost is 24.
Now, in order to find the percentage of improvement what we need to do
is take 1 and subtract this fraction here.
What we get then is right about 16.67%.
Now, for the second question--to find the approximation factor, we need to find
the optimal tour and it turns out that the optimal tour starting from A just goes way along
the outside here and if you add these up, you get 15.
And the cost of the improved tour that we were using is 20.
If we want to find the approximation factor, simply see that this is four thirds,
which is approximately 1.33.